professor alan lichtman of american
university has correctly predicted the
winner
of each presidential race since ronald
reagan's
re-election victory in 1984. back in
august
he did indeed predict that donald trump
would lose the white house based on the
president's apparent mishandling of the
coronavirus pandemic while professor
lichtman
is now calling for changes to the
electoral college vote system
and the abolition of election polls
which did predict an election landslide
and uh
he joins me now nice to speak to you
again professor uh lichtman i mean first
of all
your analysis of what's going on i mean
can we say with confidence
that joe biden is the president-elect
i predicted that joe biden would be the
president-elect back in august not
because of anything joe biden did
but because of my 13 keys to the white
house
that gauge incumbent strength and
performance and don't look at the
misleading polls
punditry or the day-to-day events of the
campaign
and we see that prediction playing out
now
in the voting counting centers
of america you know donald trump has
complained
that his lead miraculously disappeared
it didn't it's because
we're counting votes and joe biden is
going to win
the electoral college i don't care what
the networks have not declared
yet and he is on track to win 306
electoral college votes
the same as donald trump in 2016
when i predicted donald trump's win on
my totally
nonpartisan system okay then why
has donald trump lost this election
he's lost this election because of a
failure
of governance not a failure of politics
on my 13 key system
which measures how the record of the
party in power imagine it's governance
that counts
he was down only four keys in the end of
2016.
it takes six keys to count him out
but then america was hit with the
pandemic and the cries for social and
racial justice
and while donald trump acknowledged my
prediction of his win last time
he didn't understand the deeper meaning
of my system
which is that when you are the incumbent
you're judged by your record
and instead of dealing substantively
with these crisis
he reverted to his challenger playbook
and tried to talk his way
out of them it didn't work you just had
that report about
how coronavirus continues to surge at
record numbers
but this triggered the loss of three
more keys
the short and long-term economic key and
the social unrest key bringing him to
seven keys down
one more than needed to predict his
defeat and never
in the history of the united states as
an incumbent president suffered
such a sudden and dramatic reversal of
fortune
so you think it was not having policies
to deal effectively with covid and also
the black lives matter protests which
surged after the death of george floyd
absolutely it was a failure of
governance and donald trump has no one
to blame but himself
he is the president and you know as much
as
donald trump would love to deflect and
distract harry truman
former president the late president was
still right when he said
the buck stops here and the american
voters
recognize that look in the midst of a
pandemic the american people have
performed
outstandingly we have a record
turnout we have an election that despite
donald trump's bluster
is smoothly run and free
of fraud but unfortunately we've also
witnessed
the worst moment in the history of the
u.s
presidency bar none when donald trump
gets on national tv
and needlessly and dangerously attacks
our democracy with his false charges
of rampant voter fraud and he
does this just to satisfy his own ego
and for selfish political purposes
this is a incredibly low moment in the
history of the presidency but you know
the american people have come through
low moments before
are you surprised that senior
republicans
are staying silent rather than
criticizing the president because in
previous elections which i've covered
again going back to 1980
you would expect the defeated candidate
to concede to make everything easier for
the nation
i am not surprised but i am
appalled i am appalled at a president
who puts his own
ego ahead of the good
of the country and i am appalled
by these enabling republicans not only
those like the incredibly hypocritical
lindsey graham
who seems to support the president's
false and baseless charges
and those republicans are just as bad
who
have remained silent you know when good
persons are silent
that enables evil in a land
you know the best comment i've heard was
from a republican leader
who trains republican poll watchers and
he said
you know if the president is right and
the democrats are in veteran
cheaters why did they forget to cheat
in 2019 when just a tiny bit of cheating
would have given them the election just
shows how absurd the president's charges
are
okay now uh donald j trump was the 45th
president of the united states
you're a presidential historian where
would you rank him
i would rank him uh last among
presidents i think his failure to deal
with the worst pandemic in a hundred
years is the greatest dereliction of
duty
in the history of the presidency it is
needlessly cost of
tens of thousands maybe over a hundred
thousand lives
and millions of needless infections i've
also
never seen a president and i've studied
them all the way going back
to george washington who has so
relentlessly
undermined our democracy he's
politicized
the department of justice and every
department and agency
of government he has attempted to
destroy the essential checks and
balances
that our framers put into the
constitution
by stonewalling and undermining all
congressional oversight he has claimed
falsely that he can do anything he wants
us
as president under the constitution
that's not true
mr trump you're not an autocrat you are
not vladimir
putin he has rolled back virtually
a hundred or more critical environmental
regulations exposing us to the
existential threat of climate change
if we don't solve climate change and
donald trump has driven us backwards
nothing else is much going to matter
because our planet will become
almost unlivable